welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and you're now
locked into the channel where we break
down all the latest movies games TV
shows and comic books this episode we're
covering the ending of the new horror
movie the lighthouse as well as the
real-life story that inspired it
throughout this video we'll be recapping
the main events of the movie as well as
what the ending truly means and our
thoughts on the film there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to watch the lighthouse yet and
don't want to know what happens then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
make sure you like it you'll like it cuz
I said ul I'm sorry I'm sorry let's get
another breakdown five weeks due days
help me to recollect the lighthouse
centers around two characters that been
tasked with manning a lighthouse on a
desolate island located far away from
civilization you watch is both descend
into madness and the effects of living
in isolation with someone that you come
to hate the movie chronicles the
characters going stir-crazy and from the
off it's breathtaking to behold now
before we get into the plot fully we
need to discuss the characters
themselves in order to fully understand
their actions and why they eventually
choose to do what they do first up is
Thomas wake played by Willem Dafoe wake
is a superstitious untrusting character
that we learn throughout the movie
worships the light of the lighthouse on
a fanatical level and if anyone is the
bad guy in this film then it's
definitely him
Wake is an established lighthouse keeper
that's pretty much the embodiment of the
supervisor at work that takes their job
far too seriously
due to his power and status he's
borderline abusive to those beneath him
and because of this Ephraim Winslow who
also works at the lighthouse really
struggles to put up with him Efram
himself is the complete opposite of wake
and instead believes that the
superstition that way carries is just a
bunch of tall tales throughout his life
Ephraim has drifted from job to job and
able to find something that really gets
its hooks into him and because of this
he finds it difficult to respect his
superiors and those around him Ephraim
hates work
due to the sheer boredom that is created
by living on a desolate Island slowly
slips away into fantasies paranoia and
delusions if anyone is the eye of the
viewer then it's ephraim and we watch
the majority of the movie from his
perspective seeing island life is almost
torturous and unforgiving slowly ephraim
begins to fantasize about mermaid as
well as seagulls that seemed to torment
him throughout the film there's clear
allusions to the raven from the Edgar
Allan Poe story with the latter bird
constantly pestering the character but
the real torment from Winslow comes from
wake who has a bipolar relationship with
the character there's a real sense of
dread and atmosphere to the entire piece
but dotted throughout a massive moments
of humor that add levity to the horror
and slow descent into madness that we
watch the characters go through you
really don't know whether the characters
will be at each other's throats or
dancing in each other's arms and these
constant mood swings had attention to
the work that really makes it Utley
unpredictable winds slow throughout is
made to do all of the jobs that Wake
doesn't want - such as painting the side
of the lighthouse taking out human
excrement and you can really see the
character started a test wake especially
when he has ambitions of looking after
the light something that Wake is very
protective over during the movie there
are scenes dotted throughout we're awake
almost seems sexually attracted to the
light and he worships it like a deity
refusing to allow any others to go near
it due to his inability to gain access
to it
Winslow becomes obsessed with it and
also the only thing in his way which is
wake though awake on the surface seems
to be respectable as a far darker side
to him and about the midpoint of the
movie he purposely gets Winslow blind
drunk so that they missed their ride
home in the morning way comes across as
a very duplicitous character but this
darker side is also reflected in Winslow
who we discover is actually named Thomas
Howard a man that has a bad reputation
and has drifted from job to job
Howard stole Winslow's identity after he
may or may not have caused his death
during his prior work position and
though we don't ever get confirmation of
whether Howard is a killer or not
personally I believe that he is due to
the events that happen later in the
movie this identity revealed drives a
massive wedge between the two and the
surroundings of the lighthouse really
add to their paranoia
and distrust do you deny there really
being able to tell what time it is
how long they've been there for how long
they have left and who is hiding what
it's also difficult for audience members
to decide who is in the right and who is
in the wrong and because of this the
film becomes a spiral into unnerving
territory now the thing that really
sends their relationship over the edge
comes in the finale when Howard
discovers that Wake has secretly been
keeping records on his insubordination
which Howard believes will lead to him
being fired for incompetence and
therefore not getting paid angered by
this and the pressure of living together
the two come to blows and during the
fist fight Wake seems to change his
appearance several times for his final
trick Wake apparently transforms into a
man that is half human and half octopus
this is the sea god Proteus who is the
son of poseidon that possesses
shape-shifting abilities and if this
actually happens it explains how he was
able to take the form of Wake he from
and the mermaid now this could all be in
Howard's mind but whatever the case it's
clear that he believes it is happening
the movie from this point really takes
on a mystical side to it that has many
allusions to Grecian gods and after
Howard manages to kill awake during a
counter-attack he finally gains access
to the light though we never see what
Howard learns from this it clearly
dismisses him and in the final few
moments of the movie we do get some
closure on his fate in the end we see
Howard wake up on the shore with his
body and intestines being picked out by
the seagulls that taunted him throughout
the movie this is similar to the Grecian
character Prometheus who stole fire from
the gods and gifted it to humans as
punishment he was put in bondage and had
his intestines picked out every day by
birds before they grew back the next day
and he was forced to go through the
torment again similar to prometheus
Howard wishes to steal the power of the
lighthouse for himself and the entire
film can be seen as a metaphor for a
power struggle between man and God
throughout Howard covets the light but
it's consistently stopped by his ruler
Wake who refuses to share the power
because Howard disobeys this he is
punished similar to prometheus and due
to time on the island becoming an almost
abstract concept Howard may have to go
through this every day for eternity but
what is in the light well when
discussing the ending of the film
Robert Eggers the director said the
following
when you're looking at that light you're
communing with something that's not
human that's beyond human that's eternal
so this adds some way to both characters
obsession with it and why eventually
drove them to the brink of insanity they
both wanted to be part of a never ending
aspect of the universe and thus became
fixated on it
however only wake the quote-unquote God
of the island had the ability to behold
it to do his power and thus Howard was
punished to endless torment because of
his inability to stick to the rules
we've seen this motif in multiple myths
over the years whether it be Eve
coveting an apple in the Garden of Eden
or Prometheus stealing fire from the
gods
whatever the case it reminds us that we
should be careful what we wish for
because if we manage to get it there may
be disastrous consequences but what
about the real-life inspiration behind
the movie well I'd be remiss for not
mentioning that the film is clearly
based on the plan and lighthouse
disappearances that happen in December
1900 this involved the vanishing of
three lighthouse keepers who all
mysteriously disappeared without a trace
the keepers made up of Thomas Marshall
James ducat and Donald MacArthur were
all positioned on Flannan Island to Man
the lighthouse but when their relief
vessel arrived at the island to pick
them up they were nowhere to be seen
the last log mentioned bad weather
conditions and that the lighthouse
wasn't working but there was absolutely
no indication of what could have
happened or where they might have went
those certain parts of the island were
damaged they were noted in the log long
before their disappearances and
therefore it was not likely to have led
to their banishing it's one of our
biggest unsolved mysteries and to this
day there's no clear answer as to what
happened whilst they did no bad weather
there was nothing on record to indicate
that any storms had been in the area
during the time of their last entry and
because of this there exists several
conspiracy theories that range from
alien abductions to giant sea birds that
carried them away the most likely theory
is that they were swept out to sea when
trying to secure a box but many believe
that they turned on one another and had
a fight at the edge of the cliff that
led to them all falling into the sea and
drowning we may never learn what
happened but it's a fascinating tale
that definitely led to the lighthouse
being so unnerving but what did I think
of the film overall well as I'm sure you
can guess I found it in thrall II and it
completely creeped me out at several
moments there isn't really a likable
character here and because of this he
left with a film that makes you want to
see the main players go through hell
film delivers on this and whilst the
tension in the movie is at fever pitch
for majority there are still moments of
levity that elevate this above most
modern horrors the lighthouse is a
stylistic masterpiece that due to its
framing an aesthetic feels akin to older
classic horrors that have stood the test
of time as I'm sure the lighthouse no
doubt will this is a classic and from
the intro quickly cement itself as one
of the best and most unique films of the
air though it won't be for everyone to
you its tone and atmosphere the
performances here are incredible and
it's a nail-biting movie that will stick
with you long after you leave with the
air I absolutely love the lighthouse and
because of that it gets a solid 8 out of
10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the lighthouse and if you
liked it as much as I did comment below
and let me know your interpretation of
the film and if you enjoy this video
then please like it and make sure you
check out my breakdown of the hidden
countdown in the background of Joker we
went over all of the secret numbers in
the movie so it's definitely worth
checking out if you missed them and want
to know more if you want to come chat to
me after the video then make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey or head over to my discord server
which will be linked in the description
below those are the best ways to keep up
to date with all the latest videos on
the channel so hopefully I see you over
on one of them soon we're also giving
away a free copy of the Marvel phase
three part one box out blu-ray which
contains Civil War Doctor Strange
homecoming Thor Ragnarok and more and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
lighthouse in the comments section below
the winners gonna be chosen on the 15th
of November and the set will be shipped
out from the end whoever gets the prize
it's the best of luck to everyone who
takes part this is the channel for
people who are mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
you